welcome to the hugging face task series
in this video we'll take a look at the
image segmentation task
the image segmentation test divides an
image into segments where every pixel in
the image is assigned a label
this test has multiple variants instant
segmentation panoptix segmentation and
semantic segmentation
semantic segmentation is the task of
segmenting parts of an image together
which belong to the same class
semantic segmentation models assign a
probability of a class to each pixel
instant segmentation is the variant of
image segmentation where every distinct
object in the image is segmented instead
of one segment per class
panoptix segmentation segments the image
both instance wise and class wise it
assigns every pixel a distinct instance
of the class
segmentation models are evaluated on the
overlap between the predicted mask and
the ground truth mask the overlap is
called the intersection over union and
metrics such as mean average precision
are calculated on the intersection over
union
for more information about the
segmentation tasks check out the hugging
face task pages